tu avais eu des aides rien non moi j'ai
le droit à 0 aide alors forcément j'ai
attaqué Bruno Le Maire et Olivia
Grégoire sur certains médias donc j'ai
eu le bureau de Madame Grégoire qui m'a
appelé cette semaine pour savoir
qu'est-ce qui se passait donc j'ai
l'impression d'entendre Emmanuel Macron
je vous entends je vous écoute on est là
pour vous mais arrêtez votre pipeau moi
je lui ai dit ça marche pas moi votre
propagande à deux balles il y a quand
même me dire que ma comptable
elle faisait mal son travail elle était
incompétente il m'a dit il m'a dit de
vive voix que j'avais droit à toutes les
aides mais j'ai le droit à 0,1 je te le
dis à 00 parce que je rentre pas dans
les critères parce qu'il prenait les
factures d'électricité 2021 l'histoire
des compteurs des kilowatt-heure il y a
il y a un nombre incalculable de
critères qu'on nous a sorti oui
forcément les boulangers nous on n'est
pas dedans je suis désolé alors on me
dit qu'on est que les ministres ils sont
au contact des boulangers et tout mais
c'est n'importe quoi je veux dire qu'il
y a aucun boulanger qui rentre dans ses
critères donc réveillez-vous quoi c'est
moi c'est plus mon combat maintenant je
viens ici pour dénoncer tout ça mais moi
je suis mort moi c'est fini vous allez
faire je sais pas j'ai même pas le droit
au chômage ni rien je veux dire donc
je vais essayer de me reconstruire déjà
et après
j'ai 32 ans vous avez une famille vous
êtes oui oui je suis marié j'ai pas
d'enfants mais et voilà je sais pas où
je vais je sais pas où j'en sais rien
donc là aussi c'est pas depuis dimanche
c'est trop trou noir ah je suis au fond
du trou je suis sur mon canapé je reçois
les téléphones j'envoie des papiers je
veux au rendez-vous pro mais je veux
voir personne quoi c'est c'est voilà on
arrive là quoi c'est on a tué bon je
suis doté un petit village de 200
habitants on a tué le village il y a
plus les petites boulangers non il y a
plus rien c'est et puis on a servi de
proximité je me suis diversifié pour
proposer les services aux anciens aux
personnes à mobilité réduite du village
j'ai leur livrer les bouteilles de gaz
les le pain à domicile enfin c'était
voilà les gens là j'ai l'impression de
les avoir abandonnés quoi c'est la
tristesse qui avait dimanche c'était et
j'ai eu Charles merci tous les clients
j'ai eu des mots j'ai eu des j'ai eu de
l'argent j'ai eu des dons j'ai eu des
bouteilles j'ai eu tout quoi c'est là
c'est impossible de repartir ah non mais
moi je veux même plus Cyril hein je suis
dégoûté du système moi je veux même plus
mettre un pied dans une boulangerie moi
c'est fini quoi je me reconvertir avant
un boulot gagner ma vie convenablement
et plus d'emmerde plus rien je fais des
ulcères je fais des migraines des
blocages de dos je veux dire j'ai 32 ans
j'ai jamais fait ça de ma vie non non
c'est fou donc votre facture
d'électricité qui est passé donc Miley
de quoi de
10000 euros
quoi c'est on marche sur la tête on
appelle les fournisseurs d'électricité
on les a pas de nous répondre ou quand
il décroche qu'on passe 3-0 au téléphone
on a pas que ça à [ __ ] mais quand il y
a quelqu'un au téléphone mais c'est
comme ça et puis pour un bar démerde-toi
mais on va où on va où et vous ont dit
quoi le bureau de Madame Grégoire il m'a
dit qu'il m'écoutait qu'il m'entendait
qui comprenait mon désarroi ma colère ma
rage voilà et il m'a dit que ma
comptable était incompétente parce que
je devais rentrer dans les dans les
clauses pour avoir ces [ __ ] d'aide
vous avez vérifié ça mais ma comptable
elle était dessus je vous dis
tous les jours on était avec ma
comptable elle a monté des dossiers des
simulations de trucs
voilà ce qu'il m'a dit